Sweden and Finland say they want to join
NATO that's despite warnings from Moscow
with Russia's invasion of Ukraine are
those countries under threat and what
will NATO membership mean for the Nordic
region this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program I'm Adrian
Finnegan before the Russian invasion of
Ukraine NATO membership barely featured
in political debates in Finland and
Sweden but moscow's actions and nuclear
threats may have gained the Western
military Alliance two new members the
leaders of both countries have the
support of Germany where they recently
met Chancellor Olaf Schultz to talk
about Security in the region Moscow is
repeatedly warned of serious
consequences if Finland or Sweden joined
the alliance the decision will be
neither easy nor quick if they apply the
parliaments of all 30 NATO countries
need to approve new members and that
could take time
is a Biden lender and scheiden if these
two countries decide that they want to
join NATO they can count on our support
the members of the government made that
clear here in the talks and I think that
is an important signal in any case both
countries can always rely on Germany's
support regardless of NATO membership
and in the period before a decision is
made on such membership
well the leaders of Finland and Sweden
say the decision will come down to what
their respective parliaments think is in
their best security interests
as Russia wrongfully claims the right to
dictate the choices of others NATO's
open door policy is even more important
for us all have to decide on whether to
apply for NATO membership or continue on
our current path
that is the discussion we are having now
in our national Parliament
whether finland's decision will be join
NATO or not it will be based on our will
to contribute to our common security my
government is right now together with
all the political parties in the Swedish
Parliament carrying out the
supplementary security policy analysis
and this will be presented on May 13th
and the aim is that we will have very
good and thorough discussions and
Analysis within this group
the analysis include the internet future
International defense Partnerships for
Sweden and including a discussion on
NATO and all options are on the table
now before we get to our discussion
let's quickly remind you of what NATO
actually is it stands for the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization it's the
world's biggest military Alliance it was
founded in 1949 partly due to a
perceived threat posed by the Soviet
Union during the Cold War but it's not
stop expanding since the fall of the
Block it's grown from 17 countries in
1990 to 30 today it pools weapons and
resources from its member countries that
include battleships warplanes missiles
and More Than 3 million Personnel if a
NATO member is attacked the others
consider that an act of violence against
them all
foreign
so let's bring in our guests for today
from Moscow we're joined by Dimitri
babic a political analyst at inosmet the
internet media Project based in Moscow
from Helsinki oh and McNamara is
visiting research fellow at The Finnish
Institute of international Affairs and
from Brussels we're joined by
International Affairs strategist
Nicholas white gentlemen welcome to
Inside Story Dimitri let's start with
you how will Russia react if the two
countries join NATO it's threatened to
deploy nuclear weapons to the Baltic
border region and Kalin and grad should
those threats be taken seriously
now well so far the statements were
mostly made by the former prime minister
Dmitri Medway of not by President Putin
himself so I wouldn't read too much into
the statements from negative obviously
Russia is very upset and distraught uh
about the possible membership of Finland
and Sweden in NATO let me remind you
that during the Cold War relations with
these two countries were not bad with
Finland they were actually good
but in fact this membership won't bring
much will change because both Sweden
Finland took part in dozens of military
exercises in the last 10 years all of
them directed against Russia in all of
them Russia was basically almost
officially named as the potential enemy
there are NATO troops on the territory
of Finland or maybe North or on a
permanent basis but they visit and they
always have a chance to to move in very
quickly so in fact strategically this
membership will not bring much of a
change so I think most of the protests
from Moscow are like ritual protests
like this was supposed to happen I think
President Putin took it into account
when he took his decision uh on Ukraine
oh and do you think that's right that
President Putin had taken this into
account I mean How likely is it that
Sweden and Finland will become NATO
members in the near future is there any
doubts that they soon will be well it
looks more and more probable by the day
right here now I agree
surprisingly uh with Dimitri in the
sense that I don't think it will it will
make a very very big difference because
Finland and Sweden have been uh very
intensely uh cooperating uh with NATO uh
for the past decade or more but I do
crucially uh disagree with Dimitri in
the sense that these exercises and these
drills
uh through which they've been
cooperating through uh have been
directed against Russia NATO and indeed
the the independent defense postures of
Finland and Sweden uh have been uh
defensive and and defensive uh against
the Russia that has proven itself uh
ever more reventionist uh over the past
decade
um so that is how uh things have been
how things are now that both the sense
in Finland and in Sweden is that uh
although strong they're in the
independent defense capacity
is um
no longer
um enough of an insurance policy uh
considering uh the very brutal
aggression uh that we are seeing uh from
Russia in Ukraine at present and they
need an extra layer of deterrence
um and they need to be uh never again
alone and NATO's uh Collective defense
offers them uh that option so it is very
very likely uh that both States will
apply for a NATO membership within uh
the next few weeks and uh the
ratification process is is very likely
to begin at NATO's Madrid Summit in June
okay Dimitri I'll give you a chance to
come back on that and remember but let's
bring in Nicholas white then in Brussels
um Nicholas both countries are
officially non-aligned militarily uh
that they've both as we've been hearing
become NATO Partners taking part in
exercises and exchanging intelligence
both countries now permanently abandoned
their previous stance of strict
neutrality yes well if you talk to
Finnish and Swedish politicians they
will they will object that they had
abandoned this some time ago that uh
they they were no no longer being
equidistant as they had been in the Cold
War but that they were very definitely
collaborating with NATO from an external
perspective and they simply want to
convert this to an internal to to being
part of the team rather than cheering on
the sidelines but this really goes to
the harsh of the whole current conflict
and this began because the The War Began
because Russia was unhappy about Ukraine
displaying self-determination and
choosing its own path in terms of
security in terms of external alliances
now we see that the lesson that Finland
and Sweden are drawing is not that they
should take Russian concerns into
account but that they should make these
decisions autonomously for themselves
and I think it's very interesting that
the the major
um external uh intention of the Russian
war against Ukraine has backfired quite
spectacularly okay Dimitri I don't
really want to come back on on what you
heard in in those two answers there let
me put it to you that Russia's foreign
minister uh Ministry rather the
spokesperson for the foreign Ministry
insisted that Sweden and Finland are
being dragged into NATO by the U.S are
they well to a certain extent
but
but I'm willing to admit that Europe is
changing and it is changing for the wars
there are actually no more neutral
countries in the world you know for many
decades the dream of Russian
intellectuals was uh to join Europe of
neutral peaceful countries
this Europe just doesn't exist anymore I
mean Switzerland is no longer neutral
you know it depressed bank accounts of
foreign citizens it joins sanctions
against Russia against other countries
Sweden is obviously also abandoning its
neutral status surprisingly you know the
Central Asian countries uh when they
have meetings of their foreign
Ministries in that collective security
organization uh with which their members
they say that they are not directed
against any other country when you have
Summit meetings of NATO this is always
about Russian threat or Chinese threat
so unfortunately uh it's easier to find
now neutral countries surprisingly in
the previously dictatorial saturation no
longer in Europe uh as for their reasons
uh why Russia uh
basically uh continued I think the war
in Ukraine started in 2014 let's be
frank about it in fact it started in
2013
when a violent coup against President
legally elected president was started
with the support of foreign countries
and dozens of policemens were killed of
course it was not a peaceful progress so
the war started in 2015. in 2022 uh
President Putin to my mind wrongfully
decided to aggravate this war but I
absolutely disagree with the view that
actually you know Russia was unhappy
with the French independent stance no
Russia was quite happy with Ukraine
becoming independent in 1991 we had good
relations until maidan the terrible who
in 2014 for 22 years we had good
relations
but Russia was unhappy about Ukraine
actually becoming hostile to Russia you
know we are not against independent
Ukraine we are against Foster Ukraine
the same story with NATO exercises in
Sweden and Finland my colleague in
Finland said that these exercises are
not directed against Russia their own
defenses they're all defensive against
whom is Finland and against whom is
Sweden against whom are they preparing
to defend themselves it is said openly
against Russia they're not going to
defend themselves against other Norway
or Denmark of course against Russia and
this is sad because this region should
be a region of peace
and unfortunately a NATO membership it
will not be a region of Peace even
former it will be a region of military
books okay Owen do you want to come back
on that particularly Dimitri's assertion
that the war in Ukraine began in 2014
with what he describes as a violent coup
and go back uh longer than that and we
but we have a phrase in English uh Once
Bitten Twice Shy and we can go back to
the war in um in 2008 in Georgia and the
efforts of the Obama Administration
after that and we can go back into NATO
enlargement in in this effort to extend
uh liberal Democratic peace and
prosperity NATO did something very
unorthodox in the sense that it had the
it put in the pledge of no troops uh no
nukes eastwards so essentially to
reassure Russia to to show Russia its
hand in a way
um it didn't have very strong Provisions
up against uh Russia's borders which of
course are the Baltic states and the
polls had been highlighting for many
many years and and NATO to to reassure
Russia
uh uh stayed uh persistent with this uh
right up against uh right up until uh
the illegal annexation of Crimea in in
2014 and even then the NATO Readiness
action plan
um operation Atlantic resolve and later
on the enhanced forward presence uh
these deployments have been very very
light and scalable and and NATO has
relied for its deterrence on
mobilization keeping most of its troops
in the west and only saying that it will
call them up call them into the region
uh if the security situation uh
deteriorates further and uh Russia
displays even more aggression okay
um so this idea that that NATO is is is
is is the cause of this major buildup
that Russia uh is fearful of um is a red
herring uh that that is uh featuring in
the Russian narrative as they attempt to
justify
um their revisionism and uh their
efforts uh to reconsolidate and their
sphere of influence former glory uh in
central eastern Europe something uh that
Finland and Sweden uh do not want to be
part of and this is what is
um propelling uh their um
effort uh towards NATO right now okay
two questions for Nicholas uh starting
with what will Sweden and Finland bring
to to the alliance just how how useful
are they to European security oh Sweden
and Finland have got very impressive
military uh military uh establishments
um certainly On a par with any of the
decent Western European countries so
from that point of view they bring a
very professionalized well experienced
uh force of of of personnel and of
course they also closed the Strategic
Gap around the Baltic Sea of the
geographical Dimension is very very
important here they basically turn the
Baltic into a into a NATO Lake which it
previously was not so it's very helpful
couldn't they don't have them in so what
are the dangers then for The Wider
Baltic region for Estonia for Latvia for
Lithuania
um the Baltic states south of Finland of
course which also border Russia bearing
in mind that we've got the the exclave
of kaliningrad sandwiched between Poland
and Lithuania
all of these countries have been very
concerned about the potential for
aggression from Russia since their
independence in 1919 1991. and all of
them with the exception of Sweden and
Finland had already made the
determination that the best way to
preserve that Independence was to join
NATO as I said earlier this conflict
began because Russia did not accept that
Ukraine was an independent state it's
absolutely clear if you look at what
President Putin has said or other
Russian politicians have said this is
about whether countries have the right
to choose their own future Finland and
Sweden have now decided they will choose
their own future and they're choosing
their future within NATO and Russia
needs to accept that that is how the
world Works Dimitri Russia needs to
accept that's how the world works the
country's Deputy foreign minister said
that Sweden Sweden and Finland joining
NATO would seriously worsen the military
situation in the region and lead to the
most undesirable consequences what was
meant by that well I think Nico also was
quite right when see called The Vortex
and NATO Lake
whenever you have a full C uh kind of uh
you know controlled by just one military
book this is always bad it's like
Ottoman Empire Control the Black Sea in
the 17th 18th century the same story
here in fact uh the image of Sweden and
Finland and Russia is still very good we
don't want to be animals with that and
of course there is a zero chance of a
military solution like the one that
Putin used against Ukraine simply
because Finland and Sweden behave much
more racially than the corrupt and
Brazil the Nationalist Ukrainian regime
that established Itself by force in
2014. so I don't expect uh anything like
what happened in Ukraine okay but I
expect a lot of hostility and I would
expect a lot of paranoia not on our side
let me remind you that every year in
Sweden there is a paranoia about this
so-called Russian submarines
uh there was only one Soviet summary
that was once indeed fought in the in
the Swedish Waters and they got there by
accident but every year we have it all
right so this is just one example
okay start this can be about Russia let
me just throw that to Nicholas very very
pretty do you want to respond to that
Nicholas I mean Dimitri you say
so-called Russian submarines if they're
not Russian submarines where are they
from
uh and as you know last time it was
discovered that this was just a lie uh
from a person who claimed that he had
seen a submarine but there was no
summary but almost everything exist
these military operations catching
Russian submarines and they never been
any results several fans would have it
okay I I don't want to get bogged down
into into a row about about submarines
particularly Owen you're in in Helsinki
to to what extent is this NATO
membership bid bid being driven uh
unusually by Finland here that Sweden is
is actually being swept along and into
the alliance because of its eastern
neighbors desire to join well I wouldn't
say anyone is being swept along here uh
these states NATO was a democratic
Alliance and and
prospective members have to apply for
membership so all states will make their
own
um
Sovereign decisions based on on their
strategic calculations uh but yes uh
you're right uh Finland is
uh the front runner so to say among the
two states and things have have been
seismic here throughout the spring I
mean before February
24th where Russia launched its
large-scale military assault uh it's a
legal assault on Ukraine
um before that date only only a number
of weeks before that date The Finnish
prime minister Sana Marine said
um that Finnish NATO membership was very
unlikely to happen
uh during her tenure that is what she
said but because of of Russia's brutal
aggression
uh that is displayed uh in Ukraine uh
over the past
um number of months uh The Finnish
public
um has now flipped it used to be uh you
know in the last number of years 60
against uh NATO membership uh 20 for the
rest don't know now it's more than 60
for 20
against and the rest don't know so
there's been a a resounding reversal in
in favor of NATO membership
um driven uh by Russia's aggression not
driven by anything else as Finland
and the Finnish public uh now believe uh
Russia is no longer taking calculated
risks it's
it's taking uh major major risks uh as
Barack Obama reflected on Putin's
actions in Ukraine Putin has bet the
farm on this very very aggressive
um and Finland needs the maximum uh
deterrence option and the maximum uh
Collective defense option so that it's
never Finland has quite an impressive
record fighting alone but it still that
is not a desirable option and Finland
desires to be never again alone and that
is very much a bottom-up process that is
occurring here in Finland right now and
that is what is propelling
um the bid for Finnish NATO membership
forward I'm sorry to cut you short Owen
but time is is against us here a couple
of more questions for Nicholas what
changes Nicholas would membership
require both countries to make in terms
of of foreign and security policy
it's a good question and the answer is
that by and large these changes have
already been made
it will require Finland and Sweden to
align their military policy their
procurement policy uh their General
stance of Engagement in the outside
world with the North Atlantic council
with the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization but the fact is as you
mentioned in your introduction that
Finland and Sweden have already been
largely participating in the in NATO
exercises so to a large extent this
integration has already happened what
we're looking at is the formalization of
a relationship that until now has been
provisional and and transactional and
shifting it to towards something that is
more fundamental and strategic okay and
will Nicholas both countries act in
unison regarding NATO membership could
you perhaps foresee a situation where
one joins without the other and and how
long will the ratification process take
I mean Norway's prime minister is on
record as saying oh it's going to take a
matter of weeks two weeks he said that
she said is that realistic
yeah
um first of all I I would not like to
tell any Finn that their Destiny is
linked to Sweden let alone vice versa uh
the two processes will proceed
independently but in parallel it would
be the least surprising outcome if the
two of them end up joining at the same
time but other outcomes are of course
possible the ratification process first
of all everybody really is in favor of
this so it won't take all that long
having said that in some countries there
are formalities that simply take a while
to get through the president of Croatia
has mentioned that he wants to make it
the process conditional on a completely
different issue the reform of election
law in Bosnia I don't think that's a
sustainable position but it will have to
be overcome I would have thought it's
likely to take less than a year I can't
really see why it would drag on for much
longer than that even in the most
convoluted part of Entry systems okay
gentlemen there we must leave it uh
thank you to all of you for being on the
program today Dimitri Vegas in Moscow so
Owen McNamara in Helsinki and of course
in Brussels Nicholas white
as always thank you for watching don't
forget you can see the program again at
any time but just by going to the
website at altazira.com for further
discussion join us at our Facebook page
you can find that at facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story and of
course you can join the conversation on
Twitter our handle at AJ inside story
from me Adrian Finnegan and the whole
team here in Doha thanks for watching
I'll see you again bye now
[Music]